so here's what people are talking about
these days in the crypto world everybody
knows about bitcoin everybody knows
about bitcoin
all right but how much do you know about
ethereum um so i went to a bitcoin
conference and i asked people
a couple different questions it was a
big bitcoin conference in miami
i asked them to name
the top three cryptos and by far and
away bitcoin was number one it wasn't
even close
number two
was ethereum you know what number three
was
there was no uniformity around number
three there was a solana
there was a dogecoin
there was a um cardano ever there was a
lot of love spread around number three
but for sure bitcoin was number one and
ethereum was number two so here's a
story on ethereum the story from the
motley fool
is basically saying forget bitcoin
ethereum's wasn't gonna make you the
money ethereums are making the money so
here's the story while bitcoin gets all
the media attention everybody knows
about bitcoin ethereum is actually
outperforming
bitcoin as an investment the world's
second largest cryptocurrency ethereum
has a better run than bitcoin ever
since
inception that's probably because it
started off more recently as a bigger
market to address interesting bitcoin is
the leader bitcoin's the og bitcoins the
godfather ethereum's like all right i'm
gonna be second okay
basically the best way to look at is
bitcoin is like facebook
ethereum is like instagram
everybody got everybody knows about
facebook but instagram is kind of yeah
but i remember what a cool facebook also
owns instagram ah
touche
facebook
i think that
betting on bitcoin is like betting on
like a really good
nfl team
and i think that betting on ethereum is
like betting on the nfl
wow because it feels like ethereum is
just like
i want these currencies to exist
and then bitcoin is like i am the
currency wow you know i say that all the
time is that investing in a single stock
is like betting on the patriots right or
the jets or the bills
investing in an index fund
is investing in the nfl so i like that
analogy right there yeah yeah i like
that analogy i think ethereum is the the
index let's touch more on these ethereum
so basically the bitcoin community and
there's a community out there that loves
crypto loves bitcoin they basically
settled on the primary
use
for this new asset this ethereum
basically saying mostly investors
consider bitcoin to be digital gold you
hear that all the time it's gold
but it's digital
it's gold but digital all right so
what's the point of gold it's a store of
value right if you're worried about
inflation you invest in gold because it
stores your value it's non-duplicatable
it's non-fungible
i'm not sure why i'm using a tony
soprano voice for that but it seemed
appropriate
anyway
ethereum isn't trying to displace it
basically saying we're not trying to
compete with you bitcoin we're not
trying to
compete with you gold the project much
like what you said has broader ambitions
and is trying to replace the entire
internet with decentralized applications
and smart contracts you hear that all
the time it's a smart contract right
it's a contract it's pretty smart that
that contract's got pretty high iq i
don't know that contract might end up at
harvard or yale that's a yale contract
right there here's a harvard so that's
basically what's going on there with
these smart contracts and that's what
ethereum is basically
doing with their
blockchain so the target market is
traditional bonds cloud computing
sharing economy and social media which
is a much bigger market than gold so
bitcoin competing with gold ethereum is
competing with the stock market almost
like what you said right there so
let's just talk a little numbers here
and we'll get some final takeaways so
it's a smaller asset as we get that so
that's maybe why the returns are better
so year to date ethereum has delivered
over 212
compared to bitcoin's 47 that this year
2021. over the past year bitcoin is
appreciated by 300 ethers up 700 that's
over the past year the first numbers are
just for 2021. so the law of large
numbers is a play here which is why
ethereum is likely to keep
out performing so
we talk about this all the time
five percent
10
2
20
take a percentage you feel comfortable
with and get involved with crypto
100
way too aggressive yeah way too
aggressive
zero percent
way too conservative way too
conservative okay dip your toe in there
is what you're saying little dipsy doo
dunkaroo
megan the stallion was talking about so
she's dipping her toe in there toe in it
family don't don't be shy so i like that
right the water's fine yes i really like
your analogy marcelo hernandez bitcoin
is like betting
on
a team in the nfl whereas ethereum is
like betting on the entire nfl
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken